plus d'un million de morts on va tout de
suite d'écoutés emmanuel macron qui est
en direct dans cette région grand est
dans cette région qui est à ce jour la
plus touchée par l'épidémie de covin 19
est l'une des premières frappes et en
france il ya près d'un mois dans le
grand est
plusieurs centaines de nos compatriotes
ont perdu la vie plus de 700 se trouve
en état grave
placé en réanimation
je m'associe à la douleur des familles
des proches et veux leur dire que la
nation toute entière est à leurs côtés
je veux aussi ce soir salué la mémoire
des soignants qui ont payé de leur vie
leur engagement pour soigner d'autres
vies sauver d'autres vies
depuis le début de cette épidémie
le premier soignant est tombée il ya
quelques jours à compiègne trois
soignants ont perdu la vie dans la
région grand est
il avait décidé de soigner coûte que
coûte un gynécologue obstétricien ici à
mulhouse
un médecin généraliste dans la commune
de l'hôpital en moselle
un médecin généraliste à colmar une
ville elle aussi très durement touchée
nos pensées accompagnent leurs familles
leurs proches
toute la communauté des soignants mes
chers compatriotes
je vous ai dit il ya quelques jours que
nous étions engagés dans une guerre une
guerre contre un ennemi invisible ce
virus le coc u19 et sept villes ce
territoire porte les morsures de celui
ci lorsqu'on engage une guerre on s'y
engage tout entier ont s'immobilise dans
l'unité je vois dans notre pays
[Musique]
les facteurs de division les doutes
toutes celles et ceux qui voudraient
aujourd'hui fracturé le pays alors que
nous devons avoir qu'une obsession être
unis pour combattre le virus et j'en
appelle à cette unité à cet engagement
être unie et vous avez un gouvernement
qu'il est à la tâche aux rangs pour
trouver les solutions et se battent en
2010 de la santé reviendra dans les
prochains jours comme il l'a déjà fait
et comme il le fait constamment sur les
sujets les plus sensibles en toute
transparence le sujet des masques des
respirateurs des tests des traitements
pour apporter toutes les explications
toutes les demandes d'information
légitime mais sans que nous ne saignons
à aucune forme de division sans que
jamais nous ne céderons au flot de
fausses informations
nous n'avons qu'une priorité battre le
virus la nation toute entière est
mobilisée mobilisation d'abord des
services de l'état qui est totale et ici
dans le grand est depuis le début sur le
plan sanitaire d'abord tout est mis en
oeuvre pour que le service
nos services de santé puissent faire
face à la vague l'agencé régionale de
santé a lancé très tôt un appel au
volontariat des personnels soignants
plus de 1000 engagés ont répondu
présents dans la région dont 250 ici à
mulhouse une organisation
ces mises en oeuvre consistant à
déprogrammer les opérations qui n'était
pas urgente pour libérer des lits
mobilisant le secteur privé faisant
jouer toute la solidarité entre
l'hôpital le secteur privé et la ville
des respirateurs sont arrivés d'autres
hôpitaux des armées
un déploiement complet a été fait nous
avons ici dans cette région mis en place
une organisation une méthode inédite qui
sera répliquée partout où elle sera
utile solidarité aussi nationale qui
joue à plein plusieurs transferts ont
été organisés vers des régions moins
touchées
une trentaine de patients d'ainsi été
conduits dans d'autres hôpitaux de la
région
trois opérations menées par les armées
ont permis de transférer 18 patients
vers d'autres régions et demain un train
médicalisé sera affrétés pour transférer
une vingtaine de patients à nouveau la
mobilisation de nos systèmes de santé
est totale je salue et tous les
personnels de l'hôpital des hôpitaux de
la région mais aussi tous les médecins
de ville que j'ai croisés tout à l'heure
et avec qui j'ai pu discuter et
l'ensemble du secteur sanitaire médico
social et social
mobilisation aussi de tous les services
de l'état
je veux saluer les préfets qui ici aux
côtés des responsables sanitaires sont
mobilisés pour assurer la continuité des
services publics
tous les services de l'état sont
mobilisés
nos policiers et nos gendarmes nos
douaniers l'ensemble de nos
fonctionnaires
nos enseignants acquis aussi je veux
dire merci car il continue de s'occuper
de notre jeunesse de manière physique
pour les enfants de nos personnels
soignants mais de tous les autres aussi
sans relâche je veux ici aussi remercier
l'ensemble des collectivités locales la
région le département l'agglomération et
la ville et l'ensemble de leurs
personnels qui n'ont cessé d'être
également au front enfin je veux
remercier nos voisins allemands suisses
luxembourgeois qui ont pris en charge
d'une trentaine de patients lourds comme
nous l'avions fait il y a quelques
semaines pour nos voisins italiens
c'est cela aussi l'europe la vraie cette
solidarité ici dans cette première
région si lourdement touchés cette
mobilisation a été exemplaire
l'organisation a permis collectivement
de nous améliorer pour apporter une
réponse indispensable
ici nous avons fait bloc pour soigner
pour sauver c'est en activant tous les
leviers de la solidarité en faisant bloc
que nous pourrons faire face en corse où
la situation est déjà très difficile
puis demain dans les hauts de france en
bourgogne franche comté en ile-de-france
en outre-mer aussi ou une situation
extrêmement tendue sont en train
d'arriver à chacun des territoires que
je viens d'évoquer la situation chaque
jour est plus difficile et c'est la même
organisation qui se met en place
elle se met en place aussi parce qu'une
formidable mobilisation nationale est là
et je veux vous vous en féliciter vous
en remercier mes chers compatriotes la
réserve sanitaire
d'abord avec plus de 40 mille inscrits
permet d'apporter des bras des soutiens
à des femmes et des hommes qui seraient
engage pour aider plus de cent mille
d'entre vous se sont engagés sur la
plate forme je veux aider pour là aussi
à leur manière avec leurs moyens
apporter une aide au milieu de cette
crise
c'est cette france fraternelle qui nous
permettra de tenir et de vaincre mais
derrière cette organisation
il y a toujours et avant tout les femmes
et les hommes et je suis ici à mulhouse
à leurs côtés pour leur rendre hommage
dans cette guerre il y en première ligne
l'ensemble de nos soignants qu'ils
interviennent à l'hôpital en ville dans
les ehpad dans nos établissements
accueillant des personnes en situation
de handicap dans les services à domicile
qu'ils soient médecins infirmiers
ambulanciers pharmaciens aides soignants
tous sont en première ligne
les yeux sont cernés
la fatigue est présente l'angoissé là
pour eux mêmes pour leurs collègues pour
leur famille je les ai vus aujourd'hui
avec beaucoup de force
la nation toute entière est derriére
reconnaissante
elle rend hommage chaque jour elle est à
leurs côtés à chaque instant avec un
courage exceptionnel ils font face il
sauve des vies
ils font tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir
nous serons là aussi au rendez vous de
ce que nous devons au delà de cette
reconnaissance et du respect j'ai
demandé au gouvernement d'apporter une
réponse claire et forte de court terme
pour l'ensemble des personnels soignants
comme pour l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
mobilisés afin de majorer les heures
supplémentaires effectuées et sous forme
d'une prime exceptionnelle pouvoir
accompagner financièrement cette
reconnaissance mais plus largement nos
soignants qui se battent aujourd'hui
pour sauver des vie se sont hier battu
souvent pour sauver l'hôpital
notre médecine
beaucoup a été fait sans doute pas
suffisamment vite pas suffisamment fort
engagement que je prends ce soir pour
eux et pour la nation toute entière
c'est qu'à l'issue de cette crise un
plan massif d'investissements et de
revalorisation de l'ensemble des
carrières sera construit pour notre
hôpital
c'est ce que nous leur devons c'est ce
que nous devons à la nation cette
réponse sera profonde et dans la durée
je veux aussi saluer l'ensemble des
femmes et des hommes qui sont en
deuxième ligne qui permettent à nos
soignants de soigner et au pays de
continuer à vivre
ce sont les femmes et les hommes qui
transportent qui héberge qui dépanne qui
nettoie qui répare ce sont nos
agriculteurs ce sont l'ensemble des
femmes et des hommes qui sont dans le
secteur de l'alimentation des commerces
de première nécessité ce sont nos
livreurs ne caissier et nos caissières
c'est tout ce peuple travailleur de
france qui se bat qui je le sais parfois
est angoissé souvent pour eux mêmes et
leurs familles mais permet au pays de
vivre
je veux ce soir avec beaucoup de force
les remercier et leur apporter tout le
soutien de la nation
je sais les attentes qu'il y a là aussi
pour être mieux protégés et le
gouvernement fera le maximum pour
apporter toutes les réponses avec les
contraintes qui sont une autre toujours
en transparence
vendredi je rassemblerai l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux est un très gros
travail a été fait ces derniers jours
pour secteur par secteur
apporter les meilleures réponses pour
organiser le travail pour mieux protéger
au travail
je veux remercier l'ensemble des
employeurs de tous ces secteurs qui ont
beaucoup fait là aussi pour que la
nation continue à vivre cette deuxième
ligne est indispensable et je veux
remercier tous nos compatriotes qui avec
courage chaque jour
permettent au pays de continuer à vivre
dans ce contexte leur travail leur
engagement leur courage sont aussi notre
fierté et il ya la troisième ligne
celles et ceux qui peuvent télé
travailler ou rester à la maison
arrêté leur activité pendant un temps
qu'ils sont contraints parce que secteur
d'activité a fermé et qui contribue
aussi à l'effort de la nation en restant
chez eux en respectant les règles de
confinement qui ont été édictés par le
gouvernement en réduisant les contacts
en luttant contre la propagation du
virus
je vous remercie mes chers compatriotes
de cette part que vous prenez à l'effort
collectif
elle est indispensable pour protéger
notre système de santé pour ralentir ce
virus et protéger l'ensemble de nos
soignants réanimateurs permettre de
sauver un maximum de vies protéger aussi
nos aînés et les plus fragiles
chacun un rôle et dans ce contexte nos
armées ont un rôle et je veux les en
remercier je terminerai par là nous
armés sont déjà mobilisés comme ici à
mulhouse avec cet hôpital de campagne
lequel je viens de me rendre et par la
mobilisation aussi une services de santé
dans son intégralité
cet hôpital a été montée dans des délais
records par le service de santé et
l'armée de terre les cinq hôpitaux
d'instruction des armées sont aussi
mobilisés ou des malades sont déjà
prises en charge des opérations de
transports sanitaires aériens et
maritimes ont déjà été réalisés par les
avions ravitailleurs
les opérations morphée de l'armée de
l'air le porte-hélicoptère amphibie
tonnerre d'autres soutiens d'autres
missions de soutien encore partout je le
sais nos militaires sont prêts et
déterminés
nous sommes en guerre et face à ce qui
se profile ce pic de l'épidémie qui est
devant nous j'ai décidé sur proposition
de la ministre des armées et du chef
d'état major des armées de lancer
l'opération résilience cette opération
distincte de l'opération sentinelle qui
continue de se concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme
quant à elle cette opération résilience
sera entièrement consacrée à l'aide et
au soutien aux populations ainsi qu'à
l'appui aux services publics pour faire
face à l'épidémie de kovy de 19 en
métropole et en outre-mer en particulier
dans les domaines sanitaire logistique
et de la protection
dans ce cadre j'ai d'ores et déjà décidé
de déployer immédiatement le
porte-hélicoptères amphibie mistral dans
le sud de l'océan indien et à partir de
début avril
le porte-hélicoptère dixmude ira se
positionner dans la zone antilles guyane
en soutien de nos territoires
ultramarins mes chers compatriotes
mesdames messieurs je reviendrai dans
quelques jours faire un point complet de
la situation vous dire les décisions
prises pour les semaines à venir et les
décisions plus profonde que j'entends
prendre pour la nation mais ce soir je
voulais être là aux côtés de nos
soignants aux côtés de nos armées aux
côtés de nos malades pour dire que toute
la nation est engagé
engagé dans ce combat chacun a un rôle à
jouer
chaque citoyen parce que la nation
française est un bloc et parce que dans
cette guerre nous devons faire bloc être
unis fiers et reconnaissants pour le
rôle de chacun et tenir
l'unité et le courage nous permettront
de vaincre
nous ne sommes qu'au début mais nous
tiendrons nous tiendrons parce que nous
ne céderons nous ne céderons rien nous
tiendrons parce que nous en avons la
force vive la république et vive la
france
je vous remercie
merci à vous
merci mesdames messieurs
merci à nos armées merci à nos soignants